it's really like I don't think I heard
the story but when the when the the
teaser fit first came out hmm
I have like it's called kfs or clip will
file so all my life I've always had a
short neck so even from grade school I
was called no neck and whatever and
whatever and like I never really let it
define who I was and one day it was I
was in the 11th grade and I was a
gymnast but I was in the gym working out
with all the football players and we
have these it's called the neck machine
whether you can like take it and I got
stuck in it and it became the joke of
the school so I'm like oh my god people
can actually laugh at me this is kind of
funny so yeah never let it really define
who I was so shortly the the premiere
comes out like in January first where we
filmed last August I couldn't talk about
it for like five months which sucked so
finally the teacher came out I'm like oh
my god look I'm on a Vespa how fun I'm
gonna be famous and then all this hate
like a tidal wave of just they're
putting my my um making me look like a
meme like a a mucinex I mean you you
name it they were just going to town
with forget and like my publicist is
like don't read the negative stuff it's
gonna you just don't do it so I stopped
it and then sooner or later people
started to go hey give this guy a chance
let's hear what he has to say
you know don't you know body shaming why
are you doing that people started the
right letter saying this guy's authentic
and then I started to get these like I
mean a heart punch people yeah I got
this letter from Zack on the East Coast
he's like look I am I think I have the
same condition as you I'm not sure they
call it k FS do you have this you know I
it hurts for me to breathe because
people make fun of me so much and you're
rubbing mayonnaise in your hair you're
like my hero so what did I do
I hung up on him yeah I read his letter
online oh dude and now now I get letters
I get emails like from South Africa
Russia these people are going look I'm
so proud of who you are because you're
standing up to you you know and that's
the coolest thing ever in fact I get
like people like saying all this crap
about me I'm mind or like you know you
you did this for the fame you I'm like
what I I go
name one thing I did on the show okay
name one thing that I did on the show
that made myself look good go yeah right
right
then one thing that did that actually
helped me like look I just what you see
on the show which is so funny is and you
could talk to all my friends I mean I
was dancing on pool tables 12 years ago
in a nacho libre costume ah here's the
privity so I've always like laughed at
myself I've always kind of in a sort of
weird way just kind of love myself I
don't care who I don't care people like
me I like Who I am and it just an edit I
wanted to say something know you all get
it you don't think that I get comments
you fat [ __ ] you're not funny all that
stuff right and I've been getting it for
20 [ __ ] years yeah but you know what
dude it doesn't [ __ ] matter because
let me say something right right now in
terms of the internet you're the guy but
I don't believe it how is it how does
that happen I don't know how it happens
but it happens and things is this ed is
right the [ __ ] wave baby because
you're killing it who gives a [ __ ]
when you were talking about to Rappaport
who's a friend of ours you know I mean
it's like he loves you I love you I just
you know don't let those people what was
that all about
he's on my so so I shop at Trader Joe's
in Hillcrest um shout out and like I'm
so like I'm so sneaky I'm like I want to
be I do so after I film a show I'm like
hey I think I want to be famous so I
started to leave my stickers like in the
grocery store like at the checkout so
everybody knew who I was right before
you came out and then this one guy I'm
standing in line the other day and he
goes oh my god your big ad from the
needy I'm like oh my god you watch the
show he's like no no no well now I do
but I'm a fan of Michaels and when
Michael saw you go live I guess Michael
freaked out like I gotta I gotta get on
we got to get on yeah comes on just like
you you guys are so real he was just
like a person yeah and you just say you
don't get it I'm gonna get what like you
know how huge you are and just you know
and but I never want to get the big head
I just yeah take that on because that's
just I don't want to be that I just I
want to continue to be me I want to
inspire you know people and I want to be
funny like you dude you are so [ __ ]
funny I mean you just did what okay so
no laugh but about four years ago I went
got my back waxed and University in
North Park and the girl was laughing at
me she's hurt so bad yeah
feel my back for like two days yeah I'm
like screw that I'll never do that again
and one day I'm at Home Depot
right and I see this like paint roller
brush I'm like hmm so I and so I bought
the paint roller brush and then I bought
a thing in there and I put it up I mean
come on cuz I could do my chest look
back to like I mean I can show you soon
dude so listen so then I bite in there
and I'm sending my bathroom like oh [ __ ]
cuz it's not long enough sorry they go
back to the Home Depot I can get a
plunger stick and cut it down so I could
screw it in yeah all areas in my back
yeah that's that's I mean mayonnaise and
there you're a thinker and hope people
that's all you need yeah no no let me I
don't like it
are you writing this down or no no no I
have a question when when you travel to
the Philippines did you go anywhere
besides just Manila or kalo Alcon or did
you get to kind of see other islands as
well